after a long winter the sun is finally
out
the flowers are blooming and it's time
to take in the beautiful weather
your immune system is delighted it
begins celebration mode
it helps you mark the occasion with
itchy eyeballs chapped nose
sneezing and my favorite almost but not
quite sneezing
it definitely feels like your immune
system is trying to kill you
but it insists that this is what needs
to happen you shut your windows stock up
on claridin
and accept this fate because you have no
other choice
allergies were formally named over a
hundred years ago
and only seem to be getting worse for
people year after year
in most industrialized countries
allergies have increased a lot in past
decades
food allergies in particular and as much
as seasonal allergies suck
dying from peanuts sucks even more why
on earth do our bodies freak out about
things that should otherwise be harmless
evolution usually provides an
explanation for our bodies doing things
even if those things are detrimental to
us in the current day and age
sickle cell disease for example can be
deadly
but the irregular shaped red blood cells
that it's defined by has historically
given
a level of protection against malaria
the world is plagued by an obesity
epidemic because our caveman ancestors
needed
all the extra energy they could get
making us store extra calories as fat
and making us want to eat even when we
don't actually need to
but sneezing for a month straight every
spring or
going into anaphylactic shock because
you touched a peanut
what help has that ever given us as a
species
pollen isn't toxic peanuts are not
inherently poisonous
it's our body's response to them that's
the problem
conditions like this that cause swift
death
especially as a child tend to be weeded
out of the gene pool
so why are allergies still here are
allergic reactions just an evolutionary
glitch
or is there some secret to why we need
them
at the heart of allergic reactions are
lymphocytes
a type of white blood cell they help
guard your body against
foreign substances when they encounter a
particle or cell with surface marker
molecules that identify it as a foreign
invader
they produce antibodies specifically
engineered to
fight that particular threat there are
five basic types of antibodies called
immunoglobins
but the one responsible for allergic
reactions is ige
each ige antibody can be very specific
binding to one type of pollen for
example but not another
the first time an allergy prone person
encounters an
allergen like ragweed pollen for example
a large amount of ragweed ige antibodies
are produced
and attach themselves to cells called
mast cells
mast cells are a type of cell that
contain the histamines that define the
allergic response
these antibodies and mast cells then lie
dormant
until the allergen is encountered again
then after the second exposure to an
allergen
the antibodies that were created after
the first exposure are at the ready
they bind to it alerting the immune
system that it needs to be destroyed
this is similar to how the immune system
destroys
viruses but unlike in a typical immune
response against a virus
in an allergy response the antibodies
are attached to mast cells
when the immune system destroys the
allergen it also destroys the mast cell
which causes it to release its payload
of histamines
this is what causes a person to suffer
from an allergic response
and causes the sneezing wheezing and
sniffling most of us know
all too well sometimes this allergic
response can proceed to the point of
danger
some people develop hives or begin
having breathing difficulties
body tissues may swell like those in the
throat
blood pressure drops anaphylactic shock
can happen in as little as three to four
minutes after
exposure to the allergen and if it's not
treated right away
usually with epinephrine it can lead to
death
with a viral or bacterial pathogen
subsequent encounters after the first
usually pose little danger since the
body has built up a defense against it
but with allergens the opposite is true
subsequent exposures are usually worse
than the first
all this explains the what and the how
but the why is less clear
it's hard to see why natural selection
would have produced allergies
it feels like this is an immune response
designed just to make us miserable
but like all things with evolution there
is likely a purpose
or at least an explanation and one idea
involves something unexpected something
wriggling in the ground
or even in your body
parasites are more common in this world
and in our bodies than we likely realize
helmets like hookworms or tapeworms are
large macro parasites many of which are
soil transmitted
and infect the digestional tract more
than 20 percent of people on earth are
dealing with some sort of parasite
infection
we as humans have been dealing with them
throughout our evolutionary history
and the way our body reacts to these
worms is surprisingly similar to the way
it reacts to allergens when a worm
invades
the immune system recognizes proteins on
the surface of them
and responds with not just any
antibodies but ige
antibodies the same antibodies that
cause allergic reactions
before this was discovered scientists
didn't know any other purpose for the
ige antibody besides
allergies but what do pollen and worms
have to do with each other
scientists figured that there must be
some form of molecular similarity
between the proteins that cause
allergies and the proteins on the
surface of these worms
a few years ago they put this theory to
the test
they found that molecules of plant
allergens do
indeed bear a striking resemblance to
molecules produced by helminths
for example an allergen found in birch
pollen that is responsible for many
allergic symptoms in early spring
mimics a protein found in the parasitic
worm that causes bilarzia
a tropical disease caused by parasitic
worms
in fact using computer analysis
researchers found
over 2 000 parasite proteins that show
significant similarity to allergenic
proteins
so by this theory allergies are just a
case of mistaken identity
an unfortunate side effect of defense
against parasitic worms
this has been a prevailing theory since
the 80s and
many studies support it and maybe this
is part of the story
but it can't be the full story while
it's
true that the immune system makes ige
when it detects parasitic worms
one study showed that mice engineered to
be unable to make ige can still defend
against the worms
and conversely individuals with high
levels of ige
fared no better against the worms so
perhaps
ige is part of a worm defense system but
not the main component
so this begs the question what is ige
actually for if it's not even that
important
in defense against helmets the ige
antibodies surely evolved for a
different
bigger reason and on top of that not all
allergens mimic the parasite proteins
some plant ones do yes but other common
allergens like nickel or penicillin have
no resemblance
it's unlikely then that the ige antibody
evolved specifically to defend against
helmets alone
perhaps the shape of the allergens and
what they resemble
isn't the important thing but rather
what they may be associated with
the way allergic responses have been
viewed all along
is that they're an immunological mistake
but some scientists don't buy it
the persistence of allergies through
time despite its cost and burden
seems to strongly imply that there's a
reason for them
some adaptive benefit they give us to
give us a clue
let's look at what happens when the
allergic cascade is triggered
when mast cells burst and histamines are
released
in the upper gastrointestinal tract
immediate vomiting occurs
in the lower gastrointestinal region
diarrhea
and the respiratory tract constriction
of the throat and coughing
in the nasal passages sneezing in the
skin
itching that leads to scratching what do
these have in common
they are all methods to expel something
as if the body is in immediate danger
but we know it's not response against
viruses bacteria or protozoa
what else would the body need to defend
against throughout evolution
what else would merit an immediate rapid
response
the body expelling it at almost any cost
basically what could instantly harm you
toxins venom poison if
toxins bind to certain cells they can
cause irreparable harm to neurological
cardiovascular metabolic and a host of
other systems
coming across them requires urgent
action since many toxins can be
immediately harmful
thus it would make sense for our bodies
to have developed defenses against them
allergies seem like they could have
evolved to be the last line of defense
but this conundrum remains besides
certain venoms that contain allergens
most allergens are not toxic themselves
hay dust peanuts wheat or shellfish
should be harmless but here's what is
toxic
fungal spores that often invade hay dust
aflatoxins produced by parasitic fungi
that often contaminate peanuts and grain
paralytic toxins produced by algae or
plankton that often contaminate
shellfish
and of course venom itself if a toxin
is commonly coupled to a harmless
protein in the natural environment
then the immune system may have evolved
to target the carrier proteins
seeing them as guilty by association so
if you eat a clam
a peanut or in my case lobster something
in your genetic past
or your own past tells your immune
system that what you just ate
is risky stuff rather than take any
chances
it works very hard to clear it all out
and a secondary adaptive benefit to this
response
is that it trains its host to avoid
these allergens and potential toxins
things it considers too risky to deal
with i know i
certainly have no desire to eat a
lobster anytime soon
but what good is anaphylactic shock
surely that isn't a helpful response
well it kind of is the chemicals
released by mast cells cause dilation of
the peripheral blood vessels
leading to peripheral pooling of the
blood that results in a drop in blood
pressure
to keep the poison or potential poison
away from vital organs
why sometimes it proceeds to deadly
levels in some people and not
others is still not known the toxin
theory of allergies was first proposed
in 1991
and for over a decade it sounded good
but little scientific evidence existed
to support it
if the toxin theory of allergies was
true then scientists wanted to see
with data that allergies somehow do work
to protect against
toxins and in 2013 it finally got the
evidence it needed
using some mice and some bees bee stings
are known for their allergic potential
alongside the damaging venom so
researchers wanted to see
if the allergic response produced by a
bee sting
was somehow beneficial to protect
against the venom
they first injected one group of mice
with small amounts of b
venom equivalent to one or two stings
and another with saline aka nothing
then three weeks later they injected
both groups with a potentially
lethal dose of b venom and watched to
see what happened to the two groups
the mice that had been previously
injected with small doses of venom
fared significantly better they were
three times more likely to survive
but to really see if it was indeed the
allergic pathway that made this
difference
the researchers ran the same test on
three different kinds of genetically
modified mice
mice without ige mice without ige
receptors on their mast cells
and mice without mast cells altogether
and what they found was clear
that these three mutant mice types
without the key components of allergic
reactions
did not benefit from the initial
exposure to the venom
this shows us why there would be a
positive evolutionary pressure to keep
the ige
antibodies and mast cells and it totally
goes against how we generally view
allergies if allergies are always seen
as detrimental
something to be blocked with allergy
shots and antihistamines
we may be preventing a vital system from
working properly in our body
rather than focusing on how to
completely block allergic defenses
across the board
researchers are now hoping to understand
why some people's allergies climb to
deadly levels
or why allergies are on the rise
one hypothesis suggests that our modern
world is to blame for an increase in
allergies
with more pollution dietary changes and
less exposure to microbes
changing how our immune systems respond
another
the hygiene hypothesis suggests that
children are increasingly raised in a
sterile environment
getting fewer infections like the
parasitic ones we mentioned earlier
the thinking is with fewer parasites to
fight the immune system turns against
things that should be harmless
while these theories are some of the
most compelling to date scientists still
have many questions in an ongoing debate
about why we have
allergies it's going to take generations
of smart people to unravel this mystery
of the human body
but in the meantime perhaps we can start
to see allergies as
more than an annoying glitch all those
sneezes
coughs and itchy eyes might just be
stopping something worse from getting in
making videos like this is incredibly
rewarding for me
i get curious about something and then
get to spend my days finding out the
answer
and as i'm learning i get to share that
with the world in a way that makes sense
to me
all while keeping myself employed
however
the world of youtube is not always
sunshine and rainbows
as any of you who have ever ventured
into the comment section will understand
on stressful days this kind of
negativity can get to you
it's easy to feel like what you're doing
is never enough
and it's hard to carve out time to take
care of yourself
all while juggling a demanding work and
regular life schedule
and this is why i've taken it upon
myself to really get serious about
taking care of my own
mental physical and emotional health to
keep me happy in my job
and also to work to not let the negative
aspects of it
leak into my personal life and to help
me do this i'm taking the advice of
jonathan van ness in his ultimate
self-care playbook on skillshare
in it he stresses the importance of
things like writing down reminders or
affirmations of who you are
what you're doing or what's important to
you or keeping a self-care schedule for
yourself
so you can commit to activities for
yourself just like you would with
anything else
for jvn that may be needlepointing for
me it's gardening
reading in the pool or running generally
doing anything to get me off my computer
for a while
he also talks about the importance of
letting go of failures
something that i am so seriously bad at
in work and in life we may fall short of
our expectations of ourselves
and in his lessons he reminds you how to
get back on track without beating
yourself up about it
overall it may sound like obvious stuff
but for me
it's not it was a really light-hearted
funny
inspirational way to spend an afternoon
and has got me excited to let go
breathe and focus on the goals i have
for myself
this is just one of many courses on
skillshare that can help you
build life skills skillshare is an
online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes for
creative and curious people
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no distracting ads and
it's less than
10 dollars a month with an annual
subscription but the first 1 000 people
to sign up with the link in the
description will get a free trial of
skillshare
premium so you can dive into classes
about self-care
scrapbooking or productivity there's no
risk in trying it out and seeing how it
can help you shape your life
as always thanks for watching and if
you're looking for something else to
watch right now
you can watch real engineering's latest
video about the uncertain future of jet
fuel
and the end of cheap travel or my
previous video the insane biology of the
platypus
you